and book tv.org hi everybody how are you
all I'm Lilly I'm part of the event
staff at politics and prose so thank you
all for being here tonight if you're
standing there are a couple more seats
over here I recommend them and in the
front I recommend those two before we
really get started first of all we are
clearly filming tonight so we will be
very grateful if you could a silence
your cellphone's you don't want that on
there recording and B when we get to Q&A
please please please line up at our
audience mic right there and ask your
questions into the mic and finally at
the end of the night before you go by
the crisis of the middle-class
Constitution at the register over there
fold up your chair lean it against a
bookshelf we the event staff will be
very grateful all right the crisis of
the middle class Constitution is
conditioner Rahman second book after the
counter insurgents Constitution law in
the age of small Wars and this book is
both history of the idea of income
inequality in constitutional republics
spoiler ours the first constitution that
doesn't assume the idea of class
divisions and an argument that we now
need to adapt our Constitution to work
against the class inequality that we see
all over our country we all know how
important this is
in fact so important that senator
Elizabeth Warren who said that every
American needs to read this book so you
guys are doing great Ganesha Souter Amin
is an associate professor of law at
Vanderbilt and a senior fellow at the
Center for American Progress
he was policy director to Elizabeth
Warren during her successful Senate
candidate campaign and was then whose
senior counsel in the United States
Senate his writing has appeared in The
New York Times The Boston Globe Politico
and more here very glad to have him with
politics and prose so please join me to
welcome him to our stage
thank you I'd like to thank c-span for
for covering this event and thank all of
you for coming today we do still have
some empty seats both on this side here
and right up in the front so if people
want to come on down there's lots and
lots of space come on come on don't be
shy don't be shy
we're gonna be shy okay well I expect
some of you were a little skeptical
maybe about coming to this talk a book
called the crisis of the middle class
Constitution after all what more could
possibly be said about economic
inequality and the crisis of the middle
class and then you get here and you see
me and you're probably wondering what
could be said by someone who looks like
he's 12 years old
this topic well I'm gonna try to take on
this huge task you might even call it a
huge task and it's a hard task and the
reason why it's so hard is because we
know a lot about it everyone here lived
through the election of 2016 and we know
that there are a lot of people who are
really upset in the last year about
economic inequality both Bernie Sanders
and Donald Trump relied on economically
populist rhetoric and got a lot of
support for it we've all seen data on
rising economic inequality over the last
30 years we've all seen data on the
shrinking middle class and the
insecurities of the middle class over
the last generation as well but I'm not
an economist and so I want to ask a
different question is economic
inequality it's the collapse of the
middle class a constitutional problem
now you might be skeptical of that
suggestion too after all the
Constitution doesn't say anything about
the middle class in it it also doesn't
say anything about economic equality or
inequality in it explicitly if anything
these days the Constitution seems like
it gets in the way of economic of
combating economic inequality take just
the Citizens United decision which
enables wealthy people in corporations
to disproportionately influence public
policy but I think the shrinking middle
class and economic inequality are a
constitutional problem and I'm going to
try to explain to you why in this talk
for most of the history of Western
political and constitutional thought
from the ancient Greeks to the 18th
century constitutional theorists and
statesmen were very worried about the
problem of inequality economic
inequality they worried that if a
society was deeply divided into rich and
poor the rich would oppress the poor the
poor would try to confiscate the wealth
of the rich and the result would be
strife violence and revolution the
founders of this country knew that
history they were steeped in history and
they were well aware that economic
inequality was a serious source of
instability they knew that if the
wealthy took power they would slowly
start to tilt the laws so that outcomes
would favor that as John Taylor of
Caroline said in 1814 when the rich
plunder the poor it is slow and legal
the people increasingly angry at rising
economic and political inequality would
respond but not through some sort of
mass uprising they would look for a
leader to help them overthrow the
oligarchy a future Broadway sensation
Alexander Hamilton you may have heard of
him he did not give up his shot he said
in the very first of the Federalist
Papers of those men who have overturned
the liberties of Republic's the greatest
number have begun their career by paying
an obsequious court to the people
commencing demagogues and ending tyrants
oligarchy tyranny the citizens of equal
unequal Republic's confront a dire fate
so statesmen and thinkers had two
solutions to this problem the first was
to incorporate economic class right into
the structure of government in ancient
Rome for example it was a patrician
Senate for the wealthy and then there
was a Tribune of the plebs for the poor
in England of the House of Lords for the
wealthy of the House of Commons for the
poor I call these class warfare
constitutions because they build class
conflict right into the structure of
government each class has a share in
governing and also a check on the other
and this is what creates stability
the second solution was first
articulated by Aristotle who said that
the best government was a government in
which the middle class was bigger than
the rich and the poor and in which
therefore the middle class would govern
he called this a middle constitution I
call it a middle class Constitution
hence the title of the book now this
solution is something of a cheat the
idea that you don't have that many poor
people you don't have that many rich
people you have a huge middle class just
says there isn't really that much
economic inequality so you're not going
to have conflict between the rich and
the poor as a result though it means you
don't need a Tribune of the plebs you
don't need a patrician Senate you don't
need this checking system that existed
in the class warfare constitutions the
founding generation understood this
history and they believed that America
was unique in the history of the world
because the distribution of wealth here
was relatively equal now I know that
seems crazy to us but put yourself back
in the 18th century what you have is a
sparsely populated country mostly along
the eastern seaboard some towns lots of
agriculture but the center of the world
is Western Europe to the people in the
American colonies its London its Paris
and so when the people here look across
the ocean across the Atlantic what they
see are big differences
there's no feudalism in America unlike
in Europe there's no hereditary
aristocracy unlike in Europe even the
richest people here the George
Washington's and I'm sure many of you
have been to Mount Vernon it's right
down the down the road a beautiful home
but nothing compared to the palaces of
the dukes and duchesses in England
doesn't compare America had another
thing - it had vast lands to the west
and what that meant was that any white
man and it was limited to white men at
the time could become a property owner
and have a measure of economic
independence so let me just read you a
couple of brief accounts that that that
indicates some of this and the first is
from Noah Webster who we've probably
heard of the creator of our Dictionary
Webster's dictionary and he said that
inequality of property is the very soul
of a
while this continues the people will
inevitably possess both power and
freedom when this is lost power departs
liberty expires and a Commonwealth will
inevitably assume some other form the
second is is Charles Pinckney
Charles Pinckney was a delegate to the
Constitutional Convention and and here's
what he said at the convention in the
summer of 1787 he said America was not
only very different from the inhabitants
of any state we are acquainted with in
the modern world but also distinct from
either the people of Greece or Rome or
of any state we are acquainted with
among the ancients Pinckney believed
America quote had a greater equality
than is to be found among the people of
any other country and he thought that
equality would continue because quote
the nation possessed immense tracts of
uncultivated lands which would ensure
there would be few poor and few
dependent so what you see here is a
belief that first economic equality was
necessary to have a republic and second
that Americans were relatively
economically equal so the Republic would
be possible there's actually good reason
to think that they might have been right
about this - that it wasn't just a
belief that they had - economic
historians Peter Lynn dirt and Jeff
Williamson have done extensive work on
economic inequality in the founding
period and what they found is in 1774 in
the edge of the American Revolution the
top 1% in America took home 8.5 percent
of national income that's about the same
as it was in 1976 in comparison today at
the top 1% take home more than 20% of
national income huge difference
Williamson and Linder conclude that in
the late 18th century America had the
most egalitarian distribution of wealth
of any country they could calculate in
the world
so with relative equality as the
backdrop when the founding generation
adopted our Constitution they didn't
make it a class warfare Constitution
there's no Tribune of the plebs in our
system of governments there's no
property requirements for becoming a
senator the framers knew how to write
these kinds of provisions actually
debated things like
this in the constitutional convention
and in their state constitutions but
they ultimately rejected them for our
Federal Constitution and this is a
radical change this is what is deeply
radical about our Constitution it is not
a class warfare Constitution what we
have is a middle class Constitution it's
a constitution that's based on the
assumption that America had and would
continue to have relative economic
equality now over the night course of
the 19th century the economy
fundamentally changed industrialization
urbanization the closing of the frontier
the shift from artisanal work and
agriculture to wage work in factories
these developments all put pressure on
the economic foundations of our
constitutional system during the Gilded
Age economic inequality was on the rise
economic power was increasingly
concentrated in a small number of robber
barons and plutocrats and people at the
time were very worried that this was a
threat to the Republic a threat to our
constitutional system mr. Theodore
Roosevelt said there can be no real
political democracy unless there is
something approaching an economic
democracy I'm going to read you a
passage from the book here to give you a
feel for the concern of how the wealthy
would corrupt the political system
turning our government away from from a
republic and this is from the 1880s and
1890s Marcus Daly was determined to stop
William Andrews Clark Clark like Daly
was an industrial magnate who owned
copper mines mills smelters lumber banks
retail stores newspapers and utilities
but what Clark really wanted was to win
elected office in Montana partly he
wanted the status and power that came
with public leadership partly he wanted
to support policies that would improve
his business holdings and harm those of
Daly when Clark stood for Congress in
1888 Daly men pasted their hand-picked
candidates name over Clark's on ballots
leading to Clark's loss in an instance
of spectacular fraud so began Montana's
war of the copper kings over the next
two decades copper magnates in Montana
would engage in some of the most blatant
surprising and shocking
it's a corruption to gain political
power in American history
daily canceled business contracts with
those who would not support his
political aims he started his own
newspaper to compete with Clarks the two
fought over whether the state capital
would be located at anaconda dailies
company town or Helena which Clark
supported to block daily and they gave
away cigars brought rounds of drinks and
sometimes just handed out money in an
effort to garner support for one city or
the other Clark decided in 1899 that
that 1899 was his last best chance to
get into the Senate and he was willing
to pay legislators whatever it cost the
opening bid for a bribe was ten thousand
dollars a vote with many reportedly
coming in at twenty thousand and one
rumor of fifty thousand dollars for a
vote Clark son remarked that they would
send the old man to the Senate or to the
poorhouse
for his part Clark said that he had
never bought a man who wasn't for sale
by some estimates Clark spent four
hundred and thirty one thousand dollars
to buy forty seven votes in the state
legislature and offered more than two
hundred thousand that was revoked
commenting on the brazen corruption in
the election Mark Twain said of Clark he
is said to have bought legislators and
judges as other men by food and raiment
by this example he is by his example he
is so excused and so sweetened
corruption that in Montana it no longer
has an offensive smell Senator William
Clark took office in Washington only to
have investigations open immediately
after hearing testimony from state
legislators and even Montana Supreme
Court justices whom Clark's agents
attempted to bribe the Senate
investigations committee declared
Clark's election void in an amazing
maneuver Clark resigned and his allies
in Montana contrived to get the governor
out of the state making the Lieutenant
Governor Clark a lie the Acting Governor
at which point the lieutenant governor
appointed Clark to fill the now vacant
Senate seat that Clark had just been
denied this was the kind of corruption
that was going on in the Gilded Age
money buying Senate seats buying
politics shaping political outcomes and
the populist and progressives were
deeply worried that this was going to
ruin our constitutional system it would
be
end of the Republic and so they came up
with some of the most creative solutions
to this on the economic side they
invented antitrust laws to break up
consolidations of corporate power they
passed a constitutional amendment to
create an income tax in order to prevent
economic power from unduly influencing
politics they passed the first real
campaign finance reforms and they even
passed a constitutional amendment for
the direct election of US senators now
these battles continued through the
Progressive Era and even into the New
Deal but after World War two the idea
that economic inequality was a threat to
our Republic largely disappeared from
our national consciousness I think this
happened for a few reasons the first is
the new dealers largely won the battle
over whether the federal government was
constitutionally able to act in the
national economy fights over economic
policy as a result shifted from being a
constitutional debate to being just a
debate about regulation and policy the
second change was the cold war from the
founding through the 19th century and
even into the early 20th century people
who came to America the founders and the
waves of immigrants afterwards left
aristocracies and monarchies to come to
a republic they knew very well that
there was a difference between our
living in a republican living in an
aristocracy that was real to them after
World War Two the contrast shifts and
now the question is capitalism versus
communism and in that contrast fears of
communism cut against discussions of
equality even in the American tradition
the third is that we entered a period of
prosperity that economists called the
great compression GDP was up median
incomes were up America's middle class
grew larger and larger as a country we
took we undertook policies that helped
make this happen we regulated finance
Securities and Exchange Commission
glass-steagall we had we imposed taxes
are pretty high rates in this period and
we also invested in our own people to
try to get them into the middle class we
sent a generation to college through the
GI Bill we encouraged homeownership we
invested in infrastructure like highways
which both created jobs and
growth and we put into place programs
that would help lift up the poor
Medicare Medicaid headstart in this era
economic inequality simply became less
of an issue now I know some of you have
been probably thinking from the very
start you've been objecting but what
about women
what about African Americans having this
story I'm telling possibly coexist with
the reality of deep inequality between
these groups and across these groups so
in the book I distinguish between two
traditions the first is the one I've
been talking to you about so far it's
the tradition of the middle class
Constitution and the idea here is that
for there to be a republic you have to
have relative economic equality within
the political community but this leaves
open a very important question who's in
the political community and that's a
question that has been fiercely
contested including violently contested
in our history but over time we can also
trace a tradition it's booking called
the tradition of inclusion which has
expanded the political community in this
country to include women minorities I
think the key thing to think about is
what happens when these two traditions
intersect when you expand the political
community it now becomes necessary for
all new members of the political
community to also be able to join the
middle class or else the Republic can't
succeed and throughout our history
statesmen understood this after the
Civil War for example the reconstruction
Republicans fought not just for
emancipation and political rights but
also for 40 acres and a mule for an a
measure of economic independence and
I'll just read you a brief bit from
Thaddeus Stevens Thaddeus Stevens was a
Pennsylvania congressman one of the
leaders of the Reconstruction
Republicans and he had proposed a bill
confiscating the estates of the top 10%
of rebel planters and redistributing
that to the freed slaves of the south
here's what he said about his proposal
he said without this this government can
never be as it has never been a true
republic heretofore had had more the
features of aristocracy than of
democracy the start of the southern
states have been despotisms not
governments of the P
it is impossible that any practical
equality of rights can exist where a few
thousand men monopolized the whole
landed property the larger the number of
small proprietors the more safe and
stable the government after his death
one of his colleagues said of his views
he knew that a landed aristocracy and a
landless class are alike dangerous in a
republic and by a single act of justice
he would abolish both so the aim of the
Reconstruction Republicans was to link
these two traditions together
inclusivity but also the middle class
and economic equality we also forget
that this was a key part of the civil
rights movement in the 60s the march on
Washington where Martin Luther King gave
his I have a dream speech was the March
for Jobs and Freedom economics and
politics and what I think is important
about this today is we have to
understand that as we've included as
we've expanded the political community
we have to make sure that everyone has a
part and a chance to join the middle
class and this is a challenge because
we're once again in an era of increasing
economic inequality and that's why this
is a constitutional problem it's a
constitutional problem because the
Constitution wasn't designed for a
society of inequality it was designed
for a society of relative equality now
looking at the long history of republics
I think we have a couple of options for
how we can deal with this going forward
the first is that we can try to realign
this mismatch of economic equality and
our constitutional structure just by
abandoning economic equality we could
say we want to be an unequal Society
and we could embrace the class warfare
approach we give up on being a middle
class nation what would that mean what
that would mean is we would probably
have to change our constitutional
structure at a root level we might need
one house for the rich and one for the
poor we might have to resurrect the
Tribune of the plebs from Rome in fact
there's a professor at the University of
Chicago who thinks we should do just
that that we need a new Tribune of the
plebs but I think these are pretty
outlandish I
and probably unlikely to be implemented
and probably even undesirable I don't
think we want to be a country that has
fixed economic classes the second option
is that we have to rebuild our middle
class we have to reshape our economy and
we have to make our politics more
democratic now there's a lot of things
we could talk about here we talked about
raising the minimum wage organizing
workers through unions and political
movements we can talk about political
reforms from voting to campaign finance
but the bottom line is we have to do
these things not for economic reasons
not just because they're important
little tweaks to our system we have to
do these things because what's at risk
is the very core of our constitutional
system the very core of what it means to
have a republic and here's the thing the
founders would have understood this they
knew they were building a constitution
on top of a set of economic assumptions
and they knew that someday conditions
would change I'll just end you with a
quote from the father of the
Constitution James Madison who who
thought quite a bit about this problem
over the course of his life and in 1829
he sat down to compare the availability
of land the ability to move west with
the estimates for population growth and
he thought that it would be a hundred
years before America really had to
confront the problem of inequality and
here's what he said he said that when
that happened
quote the institutions and laws of the
country must be adapted and it will
require for the task all the wisdom of
the wisest Patriots I think what we need
today are wise Patriots who can help
reform our system so that we can
preserve our Republic thank you
so I'm happy to answer some questions
from anyone who's interested we have a
mic right up here in the front so feel
free to come on up get in line
questions I'll just point out I often
have a question mark at the end so if
you have questions Ivey that'd be
terrific and also if you just say your
name first names are great Caroline
poplin thank your honor um this isn't
exactly what you were talking about but
it'll give a time for other people to
think of questions I always thought the
middle class was sort of a model thing
okay we didn't it wasn't in ancient
times ancient times was like The Odyssey
you know you had aristocrats and then
you had peasants or serfs or whatever
slaves that we didn't get a middle class
until we had industry and that sort of
thing so how did aristotle come up with
this middle idea so it's a great
question and and part of the question is
what do we mean by middle class and this
is a hard question for anybody using the
phrase or even writing about it because
a lot of the time when people say the
middle class what they want is give me a
number give me a fixed dollar amount
well that's a hard thing because in
every society in every country even the
same society and same country across
time that completely changes inflation
prices there's lots of changes so dollar
amounts these kinds of things are very
difficult um
I define middle class in the book as
just saying not the very rich not the
very poor and in fact that's pretty
consistent throughout history and you
see people talking about this in these
terms for for Aristotle it's pretty
simple to see there there can be a rich
there can be a poor and he says there
could also be people in the middle the
thing that Aristotle says when he says
how come he doesn't talk much actually
in in in the politics about these middle
constitutions and and the reason why he
says is well this would be the best kind
of Constitution a middle Constitution
but
when we look around we just don't have
any societies that are mostly
middle-class people here it's all rich
and poor so for him it was very
theoretical if we move through history
you still see people talking about a
rich a poor and they recognize that
there is a middle but the middle emerges
at different times and in different
places in Florence there's a writer
named Donato Gianotti who I write about
in the book who identifies a change that
happened in Florentine politics leading
to the rise of what he calls the
mediocre I don't know
Italian so I'm probably mangling that
but it means the middle the people in
the middle the mediocre the in-between
rich and in between poor and so there's
a there's a sense of that to James
Harrington in England in the 17th
century recognized that there are these
peoples in the middle in the 18th
century you see lots of people in early
America they don't use a phrase
middle-class but what they say is the
middling people the middling sort and
somewhere in between the wealthy and the
poor the middle-class itself really does
take prominence as you started in the
Victorian era as a phrase but but I
think the the basic idea of it is
actually pretty consistent throughout
the political thought of the centuries
before that interesting thank you
yeah let me thank you for a very
interesting talk I have a few questions
um I'm uh suffice I'm from the Caribbean
so I'm from a little different part of
the world and I started loan in
netherland so I come from it from a
different angle to and I was somewhat
surprised that you declared obviously
the the American resolution to be a kind
of a middle class Constitution right I
mean I'm sure you know the the writing
is a via the the great political writer
who pointed out how the Constitution was
written in the United States right but
mostly by wealthy people to put that
word the interest granted there was a
lot of land and there was a
opportunities for certain people to get
in but but issue is it was written
basically to protect certain interests
and the issue becomes aren't those
interests really no coming home you know
to use Malcolm X the chickens coming
home to roost there are sudden extent
right so that would be the first
question the second question would be
that obviously I mean you you're we
thought to me let me do that for myself
right could be well just made here the
right is yet but you had to a certain
extent certainly between as you pointed
out right it's great income equalization
you know between brackets obviously
between 1945 and 1980 right I mean in
Europe you know I grew up in Europe I
mean I sighed and I saw I remember one
day walking for my university Trek home
and it was something I was maybe 19 18
19 I'm thinking there's something wrong
in the society something is coming apart
in the snowing you know but drivers
passing telling me to get in the bus I'm
going to freeze I'm like leave me alone
I need the I'm thinking don't bother me
and it came to me what had happened that
basically what you had in these
societies in Western societies right was
the largest solidarity mechanism
starting to fracture and break apart
right the kids of
the working-class no we're moving up
they're becoming educated and they
didn't have much relationships as their
fathers had with the working class in
the war so they didn't feel this need
for a social welfare state anything that
was about rents today right so the issue
is obviously for this thing to walk all
of the institutions have to walk in a
certain way at a certain time together
once you get the Supreme Court path by
fundamentally right-wing people you get
a political system packed by
increasingly right-wing people who don't
really reflect me we know Hillary
Clinton won by three million votes right
basically the guy lose the election he's
still president right so so the system
itself is a huge problem so the issue is
arm and the issues that you put forward
also seem to me that the man right you
you didn't touch on them to demand a
much more radical redistribution yes
a much more radical redistribution of
income and power right a much more
economic democracy so how do you think
about these issues and do you see any
move anywhere because this is not a
United States I mean look I'm so called
French Dutch France marine lepen could
be President Dutch in Holland here will
is just when significant amount of votes
so how do you see this playing out and
do you sleep do you have a lot of
optimism of how this is gonna play out
thank you thanks great questions so on
the first question so a little bit of
background about a century ago there was
a historian named Charles beard and he
wrote a book called the economic
interpretation of the Constitution very
famous book and in the book he argued
that the Constitution was designed by
the founders basically to rig the system
to serve their own personal economic
interests and he went there in great
detail showing the different interests
of all the particular people at the
Constitutional Convention and so on
trying to link that up to outcomes of
the Constitution this thesis which
really sticks with us I think a lot of
people in the historical imagination was
actually decisively debunked by
historians in the 1950s who went back
through all the evidence and showed that
beard was wrong
and so on the specific claim that the
Constitution was rigged by the
to serve their own personal interests
there isn't much to that but but the
broader claim is still a very powerful
one that the Constitution was rigged by
people to try to establish a more
aristocratic form of government but I
think the challenge that we have to ask
ourselves if we think about the
Constitution that way is why didn't they
rig it more and just think about that
though the whole history of governments
before that included things like
property qualifications for members of
upper houses like the Senate even for
the house representatives potentially
you could imagine designing a system
that way the 1780 constitution of
Massachusetts the longest standing
constitution in the in the in the
history of the world
um written by John Adams had property
qualifications in it for the governor
for the Senators it was deeply
aristocratic these kind of designs were
debated wide widely throughout the
colonies in the time and rejected that
is a radical change and the reason that
they were rejected there's a number of
reasons some are practical how exactly
would you design these things and so on
they debated those things but one of the
things that you see consistently in the
reports in the the notes from the
Constitutional Convention is them
referring to the people who were absent
at the Constitutional Convention and
that's the people and they knew what the
people wanted and they knew what the
people believed which was that this was
actually an equal society and they
couldn't rig the system more without
running afoul of what the people would
accept and what the people really wanted
and so the founding generation the
people who ratified the Constitution
when they when what when they when they
were embracing it we're not embracing a
document that they thought was rigged
for the system you don't see people who
are Federalists making the argument this
is a great Constitution because it
entrenches the elite and will overthrow
all the power of the people that's not
what they say what they say is this is a
great Constitution because every aspect
of it draws some directly some
indirectly from the great fountain of
the people the great part of the
democracy everything is rooted into in
that
and so there was a sense at this time
that that was a real constraint of real
a thing that people believed and so
that's why they didn't rig it more so I
think that's the way we need to think
about it the baseline isn't how we think
about democracy today the baseline for
them is looking at 2000 years of history
and looking at the European experience
and on that grounds I think it's a quite
radical document to your second question
how should we think about the changes we
need today there are a lot of things
like I said and and we could go into
these I'm sure being in Washington
there's many policy experts in each of
these areas but you know we talk a lot
about about things like the minimum wage
it's a way to lift wages up we talk
about redistributed mechanisms taxes
transfer programs but there's also
front-end things you can do but one
scholar is called predistribution
thinking about how the economy runs so
that it generates more equal
distribution of wealth antitrust for the
progressives as I suggest in the book
was was one of the ways they thought
about this and the idea here is that if
you have a nation of small business
owners small proprietors what you have
is not a massive concentration of wealth
in the few you have it being distributed
across everyone and so the antitrust was
partly about that and and what's very
interesting is when you go back and look
at whether it's a louis brandeis
roosevelt or others when they talk about
antitrust they often talk about it in
constitutional terms that it is
essential to break up consolidations of
power to preserve our republic to
preserve our constitutional system and
as you were speaking I found myself sort
of thinking throughout you know what
happens if we we take this
interpretation and sort of flip it on
its head so I've heard the argument
advanced that a certain amount of
inequality is is good in a society but
if you see that in the argument that
well there's it's an incentive and it's
an economic driver having the
opportunity to to move from one class to
another you know motivates people who
work in fact having another class is
what provides that incentive I'm curious
how you would approach that if you know
perhaps the other alternative
interpretation would be not that
equality was presupposed in the frame of
the constitution but rather that
inequality was presupposed and was
accepted to be a good thing or that a
certain amount nowhere where that amount
of what's good and what's too much of
course is a large field for debate but
um you know similarly I've you know I
recall being in elementary school and
have been taught time and time again how
our own legislature mirrors that of the
the Roman Republic upper house lower
house and so on as opposed to being
different in fact is modeled on that
very same thought process which involves
a an upper and a lower class so I'm just
kind of curious you know what your
thought process is in terms of what
happens when we take that argument kind
of just look at certainly flip the
concavity of it look at the mirror image
and start thinking in terms of you know
what inequalities role is great thanks
for the question um so you know to start
with the second part of it I'm thinking
about the Roman case I'll just stress
again the the key difference actually
between our system and the prior systems
is that it doesn't build in class
directly into the structure of
government and this is a hard thing to
tell in some cases because we think of
the Senate maybe as the Roman Senate or
as the House of Lords and we think of
the House of Commons as the House of
Representatives but there was a big
difference in how people thought of
these over time and the shift the
radical thing that James Madison
explains in the Federalist Papers is
that our and actually see this
throughout the debates and the
ratification of the Constitution is that
our system of separation of powers is
not based on checking and balancing
classes it's based on checking and
balancing just different institutions
it's the president it's one house of
legislature it's another house of
legislature but the whole idea is this
is not about classes and and and what
they say is why is this why would it
ever be about classes we don't have
classes here that we would need to check
against each other and that is something
that you see said in these debates um on
the broader question about inequality
you know the the idea tourism that
there's perfect equality certainly there
was not perfect equality at the time of
the founding far from it there are big
differences but the differences are not
extreme and around that the huge extreme
levels that you would see
either in Europe at the time or really
even see today and I think that's the
ideas that there's got to be a range
that is is broad and one thing I'll say
about this is how culturally this is
important so you talked a little bit
about the need to spur people to to act
but the other side of this is what it
takes to have a virtuous citizenry and
one of the things that's surprising I
think to a lot of modern ears when you
read the founding generation is how
skeptical they were of Commerce and
they're very skeptical of Commerce
because they thought it would destroy
virtue and one of the important things
about the middle class is it gives
everyone a measure of being similar to
each other and a measure of economic
independence and both of those things
they thought developed the kinds of
virtues that were needed for people to
be equal citizens in a republic and so I
think that's another way of thinking
about the the same set of ideas that
they're that this is really a different
world where they have different
considerations things like virtue are
are at the forefront of their minds
good-evening it joel heller a lot of the
examples you gave for the idea that at
the time of the founding america was
kind of premise 10 an idea of equality
had to do with property ownership and so
do you have any examples aside from that
that show this idea of a economic
equality was kind of built into the
system and also do you think property
ownership still needs to be part of the
constitution or part of the the
conversation today when talking about
restoring the middle class so most of
the founders talk quite a bit about
property the reason is because property
was the primary mode of wealth at the
time and there was a lot of land
property available here in in America so
property is really core to how people
think about this and you see it
throughout the writings of basically
every one of the the leading founders
maybe most famous is Jefferson who says
when he gets rid of the end tale which
is a way to link property to your
descendants over time if you've seen the
if you've watched Downton Abbey the very
first season is all about the end tale
this made property law professors just
giddy with delight for 30 years that pop
culture knew the end tale so but what
Jefferson said
is that when he tried to get rid of the
entail and succeeded he quill laid the
axe to the pseudo aristocracy because
this was what was going property
distribution was the key way that the
narrow stock receive would develop over
time so that's a big part of it um but
there is a sense that you know there
were other people in the time the
founding who weren't just you know
farmers there was a lot of artisanal
labor at the time and again the idea
there though is people are owners of
their own work they are independent and
they act separately there were some
merchants there was a merchant set of
people but the comparison in what
merchants made even between America and
Europe was pretty stark so by one
account the wealthiest merchants in
America had wealth levels of about fifty
thousand British pounds compared to in
London where the wealthiest merchants
were around eight hundred thousand
pounds so that's a factor of ten plus in
thinking about just the the differences
among merchants so I think even in the
cases where we're not talking about just
farmers in agricultural land there there
were stark differences between America
and Europe thank you
organize thank you I'm wondering about
the the role of political populism in
relation to inequality sort of
historically but of course especially in
the present context it seems like
populism ought to have thought to
potentially be a sort of process that
society goes through to sort of react to
rising inequality maybe it doesn't
always work that way I don't know but
historically can you say that it
typically works that way and given and
if that is true then given that now we
have inequality rising inequality we
also have rising populism disease that
hold some hope for the future great
question so uh you do see populism
throughout American history um and and
all and and and it comes in waves it
comes often at times of fear of
inequality fear in the changing economy
the Jacksonians are populist at a time
when there's big changes in commerce one
scholar calls this period the market
revolution the expansion of commerce in
the 1820s or so and Jacksonian populate
populism is in part a reaction to that
in the late nineteenth century during
the Gilded Age you have the populist the
party we know is the populist but a
group of people also that we consider a
populist of the small P the Knights of
Labor the farmers alliance there's a
wide variety of these groups that
organize and and and really try to
change the nature of the economy doing
some of the things like I suggested
antitrust income taxes but in fact the
populist in that period actually really
pre-staged many many of the 20th
century's goals they advocated for the
eight-hour workday for banning child
labor they actually used the phrase
equal pay for equal work referring to
women getting paid equally this is way
back in the in the late nineteenth
century
there's populist and it's not all
populist but there was a strand of
populist that tried to unite
african-americans and white
working-class people in the South even
and they organized them they pushed hard
to try to link across across race in
order to push back against what they saw
as a planter aristocracy that was
keeping down both races that effort
failed obviously but but but there was a
lot of populism at different times to
push back against this and so one of the
things I think is most striking that I
found in researching the book is how
many times change happened because of
real grassroots action if required
leaders also there's always there are
always leaders Teddy Roosevelt's and
others but there was massive
mobilization on the ground and so one
example of this is the United States
passes a corporate tax in 1895 and this
is partly a response to the panic of
1893 and the massive depression that
follows and people get organized they
are angry there's marching in the
streets there's violence and this is an
element of populism it leads to economic
change and I'm not advocating for for
violence certainly but the idea that
people who are really engaged can push
political actors to be responsive to
their needs is an important one really
drove a lot of the progressive changes
both on the economic side and on the
political side my name is Bonnie
Narad say and you spoke about Aristotle
talking about the great middle class as
it was at that time as I recall he he
wrote about having serious doubts about
a democracy because he said that the
democracy leads to tyranny and so what
was important to him was education and
that the educated people be the ones to
be in the hierarchy the ruling hierarchy
the benevolent ruling hierarchy so you
haven't said anything about education
but you've talked about owning property
kind of an equality of wages and
everything what's the connection with
education
since we're mindful of the fact that the
current person who's sometimes sits in
the White House he's said I just love
and educated people because they're the
ones who vote for me your thoughts so
education
well there's multiple ways we can think
about education in the context of the
system so the first is we might have a
link between education and the middle
class or the education and economic so
some people think and define the middle
class based on education and so that
gets back to our conversation earlier
about how we think about what is the
middle class there's another idea that
we have largely 20th century idea but
there's an element of in the 19th
century to that education is the best
maybe even the only way to move forward
into the middle class and there's a book
by a couple of economists called the
race between education and technology
which suggests that education is the way
to stay ahead of technological changes
and still be able to be successful in
the new economy so we could think about
education on the economic side of the
ledger on the political or
constitutional side of the ledger a
number of people throughout our history
have believed that education was very
important for having a virtuous
citizenry for having citizens who
understood their duties understood their
responsibilities in the society and so
education was a key component of that
but they also thought that education was
important for uniting us as a people so
many of the founding generation
advocated for example for a national
university
James Madison one point said he thought
this would be good because it would help
build social harmony across different
kinds of people's there was an element
of bringing people together in the 19th
century you see the land-grant colleges
which are both an element of Economic
Opportunity but also are there to help
build an educated citizenry throughout
the West and throughout the the growing
expanse of the country and so I think
education plays a role in in many of
these different dimensions and and is an
important one I'll just add one other
thing about how education can be
experiential and helped lead to virtue
in the in the Gilded Age period the
populist s' many of them thought that
the answer to the prowl
of their period which was basically the
creation of the corporation that's what
they saw is the big one of the big
innovations where they're now owners
shareholders and then wage workers was
not socialism it wasn't national
ownership
it was creating cooperatives and the
idea of the co-operative was that the
workers would both be owners and workers
but they would also share in governing
the cooperative in governing corporation
and that would train them in the process
of making hard choices learning how the
institution ran and these would be the
kind of virtues that are good for the
education of a middle class person but
also of a citizen who has to deliberate
on national questions where there are
trade-offs and where there are real
challenges as well so there's different
kinds of ways to think about education
in that context where's gonna take these
last two questions oh thank you for
coming here on on foreign as well so I
was bit disappointed for you not
bringing up Scandinavia but they're they
they really stabbed with something in
their equality hard taxation welfare
system as the what how he could was such
a thing when the only thing Americans
think about is reducing taxes
I think that's very important one
welfare you know yeah welfare I I
believe that a lot of Americans thing
welfare systems is useless thing and you
did not mention welfare so I just want
you to comment in this yeah so so when
we talk about inequality there's a few
different things we can and should talk
about one is the difference between the
well let's let's split up we have three
categories we could talk about the poor
we could talk about the middle we could
talk about the rich there was a period
of time in our history where the biggest
divides the biggest problems were
between the poor in the middle and
actually in the period of the the great
compression the period after World War
two
late 50s early 60s there was a lot of
poverty in America desperate poverty in
America and there was a big divide
between the poor in the middle even
though we were relatively equal as a
society a lot of policy things helped
solve those problems as I mentioned in
the talk Medicare Medicaid had start
many of the welfare programs programs of
the Great Society we're hugely important
in alleviating poverty these programs
largely succeeded at doing so another
problem we could talk about in
inequality is the difference between the
very rich and everyone else and that's
actually more where today there is a
problem is is that we see a greater and
greater share the economists tell us of
wealth going to the wealthiest people in
our society and then that is the thing
that leads to the possibilities of
oligarchy aristocracy and so on that
we've been talking about so I think
there's an important component to play
at the lowest end but but but at the
moment I think some of the biggest
threats to our republic come from the
threat of oligarchy more than anything
else thank you very much for coming my
name is sterling I'm looking forward to
reading your book what do you think is
the impact of technology on wealth
inequality since there's your microphone
I can't help myself
you know what March Madness is going on
you've got a few of these basketball
players that will go on to the pros and
they'll make an incredible amount of
money the difference between you used an
example of George Washington George
Washington and now as I see it one of
the main differences is Seward
technology so my question is the the
impact of technology on wealth
inequality so I think there's a lot of
things that impact inequality and as I
started I'm not an economist I won't I
won't pretend to choose which ones are
the most important or rank them or
anything like that but technology is got
to be part of the story here and the
reason why is we've become more
productive through technology but when
that happens people lose jobs and the
question is can people go back and get
retrained or rescaled or get other jobs
a great example of this that we're all
probably aware of the looms large in our
future is in most states one of if not
the number one job is driving driving
trucks especially we now have
self-driving cars in a few years we may
have self-driving trucks we may have
them everywhere and that'll be a lot of
people who lose their livelihoods
potentially over a technological
innovation that has great promise in a
variety of other in a variety of other
arenas for example fewer accidents
potentially more productivity for people
being able to drive all night long
machine can drive all night long doesn't
need to sleep doesn't need to take
breaks but so there's a there's a
challenge of how we deal in a world of
increasing technology with the fact that
some people are going to be very deeply
disproportionately impacted by this and
I think we see that all over all over
America that it's very very hard to
figure out how you can retrain or
rescale for the new jobs of the future
but that's one of our big challenges I
think that's a core part of what people
today when I talked about the wisest
Patriots need to be thinking about is
how are we going to confront these
challenges of the future head-on and and
try to solve them
so as I mentioned at the start I'm gonna
hang out here and and sign some books if
you get them and come on up
we'll we'll do that right now